la parole est maintenant notre collègue
mathieu darnaud pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole donc
chers collègues
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des finances et des
comptes publics monsieur le ministre au
mois de janvier le gouvernement et la
majorité ont salué l'avènement d'un
gouvernement de gauche radicale en grèce
hélas hier comme aujourd'hui neil
aveuglement idéologique ni le déni des
réalités ne permette à quelque
gouvernement que ce soit de sortir d'une
crise et de redresser un pays alors que
les lourds efforts consentis par les
grecs ces dernières années commencer à
porter leurs fruits avec le retour de la
croissance le premier ministre grec a
préféré gâcher ce redressement par un
visa un virage irresponsable sa gestion
hasardeuse et démagogique et frappé d'un
échec total
décrédibilisant la parole d'un pays qui
est pourtant le berceau philosophique de
l'europe et offrandes assisté à des
scènes de files d'attentes devant les
guichets des banques qu'on pensait d'un
autre âge la grèce et ses partenaires
étaient proches d'un accord mais
monsieur trip type race plutôt que
d'entrer dans l'histoire comme un homme
d'état lucide et courageux à préférer se
défausser de sa responsabilité en
convoquant un référendum comme si
excusez du peu il découvrait le problème
est d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre
avoir un regard critique ne chine y
avoir un regard critique ne signifie pas
remettre en cause la démocratie
face à cela monsieur le ministre la
france deuxième économie de la zone euro
est exposée à hauteur de 40 milliards
d'euros et reste pourtant peu audible
non seulement le président de la
république n'a pas réussi à convaincre
le premier ministre grec de renoncer au
référendum mais il a rompu la force du
couple franco allemand pire encore il a
provoqué la mise à l'écart de notre pays
dans la gestion de cette crise et
d'ailleurs j'observe et nous observons
avec intérêt monsieur le ministre que
dans vos propos on note une certaine
inflexion avec des propos sensiblement
différent de celui du président de la
république à l'opposé de la position
française les ministres des finances de
la zone euro se sont finalement aligné
sur la position de l'allemagne celle-ci
assumons à elle seule le rôle de moteur
des négociations et décidant de ne pas
reprendre des discussions dans l'impasse
avancez à votre cul si au grand dôme
grecque monsieur le ministre ma question
est donc simple quand allez vous adaptez
la position du gouvernement français à
la réalité de l'équipe dirigeante
grecque et redonner à notre pays le rôle
et l'audience qui devait être le sien
dans cette crise merci
la collègue par les communistes des
finances des comptes publics michel
sapin merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur il ya
toute une partie de votre question qui
est la critique en règle d'un
gouvernement étranger je vous la laisse
ce n'est pas ainsi que nous pensons
pouvoir mener le dialogue avec les uns
et les autres le premier principe que
nous devons avoir c'est celui du respect
d'un gouvernement démocratiquement élu
et d'une majorité démocratiquement élu
la deuxième chose monsieur le sénateur
deuxième chose c'est le sénateur
je ne vous ai pas vus c'est normal
présent au sein de l'eurogroupe ce qu'on
appelle l'eurogroupe c'est le lieu où se
réunissent les ministres des finances de
l'ensemble des pays de l'europe ainsi
que la commission le fonds monétaire
international la banque centrale
européenne le tout sous la présidence du
président de l'eurogroupe la différence
entre vous et moi c'est que moi j'y
étais et que je sais quel a été le rôle
de la france et si vous y étiez ou si
vous pouviez interroger les uns et les
autres vous ne feriez pas ce genre de
remarques qui non seulement est
désobligeantes vis-à-vis de moi même ça
ça n'a aucune importance mais qu'est
désobligeantes vis-à-vis de notre pays
parce que notre pays joue un rôle
fondamental dans le dialogue actuel dans
la capacité à faire en sorte que toute
l'europe tous les pays de l'euro
continue à dialoguer avec la grèce parce
que le pire qui pourrait arriver d'abord
à la grèce c'est de sortir de l'euro
mais ce serait aussi une difficulté pour
les autres pays et surtout ce serait une
atteinte profonde à notre projet
européen le projet européen c'est
d'avancer et non pas de reculer c'est
d'accueillir et non pas d'exclure tel ou
tel pays la france a été présente du en
bout elle le sera encore pour faire en
sorte que ce soit le dialogue qui soient
au premier plan et puis je les dis très
clairement il n'y a aucune contradiction
à partir du moment où le premier
ministre hier a dit il y à un référendum
et j'appelle à voter non j'ai dit ce
matin je ne sais pas à conclure un
accord avec quelqu'un qui vous dit non
c'est clair c'est simple et c'est net et
c'est la position et c'est la position
que l'eurogroupe a pris à l'unanimité
et si je voulais trahir un tout petit
peu les débats de cet eurogroupe c'est
moi qui ai fait la proposition
quincy soif qu'il en soit ainsi fait au
sein de l'eurogroupe à l'unanimité est
c'est normal et maintenant nous
attendons le débat démocratique le
résultat du débat démocratique et ce
sont les grecs qui aujourd'hui vont
avoir à décider est ce qu'ils veulent on
continue à négocier dans la sérénité
même si c'est difficile où est-ce qu'ils
le veulent prendre le chemin de
l'inconnu je pense qu'il vaut mieux
éviter l'inconnu merci